let us now come back to the trajectory
estimation problem that we introduced
earlier we have an object that moves
vertically at any given time T the
height at which the object is found is
equal to this expression it corresponds
to the following the object starts at
time 0 at some initial height theta 0 it
has an initial velocity of theta 1 but
also has a certain acceleration and if
theta 2 is negative this will be a
downwards acceleration which means that
the object eventually will turn and
start going down so this is a typical
trajectory of such an object where here
we are plotting the height as a function
of time
however the Thetas are unknown and
they're random we do not know what they
are so this blue curve is just a
simulation where we drew values for
those random variables at random but if
we were to simulate again we might
obtain a somewhat different blue curve
because the values of the Thetas might
have been different we do not observe
the true trajectory directly what we do
observe is certain data points what are
they at certain times TI we make a
measurement of the height of the object
except that this measurement is
corrupted by some additive noise this is
the model that we introduced earlier and
our assumptions were that all the random
variables involved the Thetas and the WS
were normal with zero mean and were also
independent in that case we saw that
maximizing the posterior distribution of
the Thetas after taking logarithms
amounted to minimizing this quadratic
function of the Thetas so once we have
some data available in our hands we look
at this expression as a function of the
Thetas and find the Thetas that are as
good as possible in terms of this
criterion and this is the map
methodology for this particular example
now for the purposes of this
illustration actually
we will change our assumptions a little
bit there will be as follows
regarding the acceleration we will take
it to be a constant the acceleration
term often has to do with gravitational
effects which are known so we will treat
theta two as a constant and that means
that there is no point in having a prior
distribution for theta two so this term
here which originated from the prior
distribution of theta two is going to
disappear we will take the variances of
these basic random variables to be the
same and because of these these
constants here will all be the same
therefore we can take them outside this
expression and outside the minimization
they will not matter so we can remove
them from the picture the factor of one
half can also be removed similarly does
not affect the minimization finally just
in order to get a nicer illustration
instead of taking zero means we're
assuming that the initial position has a
mean of 200 so we're starting somewhere
around here and furthermore the initial
velocity has a mean of 50 so we expect
the object to start moving upwards how
does this change the formulation we'll
remember that this term and this term
originated from the priors for theta
naught and theta one if we now change
the means the priors will change and
what happens if you recall the formula
for the normal PDF and how the mean
enters after you take logarithms you see
that instead of having here theta naught
you should have theta naught minus the
mean of theta naught squared and this
leads us to the following formulation so
this is the formulation that we will
consider we obtain these data points and
for this particular data points and for
known times at which the measurements
were taken we put these numbers into
this minimization carried it out
numerically and this is what we got we
got asked
for the different parameters and using
these estimates we can use this
expression to construct an estimated
trajectory and the estimated trajectory
is given by the red curve it seems to be
doing somewhat of a reasonable job but
not quite the distance between these two
curves is quite substantial how could we
do a little better why is it that we're
not doing very well let's think
intuitively one of the parameters we
wish to estimate is theta one and theta
one is a velocity now all of our
measurements are concentrated at pretty
much the same time but if you measure an
object only at a certain time it is very
difficult to estimate its velocity a
much better idea would be to try to
measure the position of the object at
different times and use that information
to estimate velocity so let us instead
instead of taking all the measurements
around the initial time have five
measurements in the beginning and five
measurements towards the end the total
number of measurements in this example
is the same as in the previous example
once more we generate a simulated
trajectory according to the probability
distributions that we are assuming then
we generate data according to this model
and we wish to estimate this trajectory
we take the data plug them into this
minimization carried out numerically and
this is what we obtain so we see that
here we are doing a lot better the
estimated trajectory is quite close to
the unknown blue trajectory even though
the data seems to be scattered quite a
bit this is a very nice property but is
it just an accident of this numerical
experiment or also to put it differently
once you get your estimated trajectory
yes it is true that it is close to the
blue trajectory but you do not
necessarily know that fact it is one
thing to have an estimate that is close
to the true value and it's a different
thing to have an estimate that you know
that it is close to the true value so
how could we get some guarantees that
indeed this is the case that we have
good estimates here is how it goes as we
discussed before the posterior
distribution of the Thetas given the
data is normal and for similar reasons
the posterior distribution of this
quantity which is the true position it's
what we denoted by X of T the posterior
distribution of X of T is also normal
and in fact what we obtained from this
diagram is at any given point it's the
maximum a posteriori probability
estimate of the position X of T at that
time however besides just this point
estimate we have additional information
we know that the posterior distribution
of X of T is normal and so for example
at this time this is the peak of the
posterior this is the maximum posteriori
probability estimate but we are also
able to calculate the variance of this
posterior distribution this is a
calculation that's a bit complicated for
the multivariate case for the case where
you have multiple unknown parameters we
will not get into it but we did see
earlier an example where we had a single
unknown parameter and in which we were
able to calculate the variance of the
posterior distribution so the idea is
somewhat similar so not only we have an
estimate for the position of the objects
at this particular time but we also have
a probability distribution for what the
true position might be and once we have
such a posterior probability
distribution we can find an interval
with the property that 95% of the
probability is inside that into
in other words we construct an interval
with the property that the probability
that X of T belongs to the interval now
we're talking about posterior
probabilities so it is a posterior
probability given the data this
probability is let's say point 95 such
an interval gives us useful information
besides a point estimate it also gives
us a range of possible values and
outside this range it is quite unlikely
to have the true trajectory be out there
so here we're showing some confidence
intervals that apply to different times
and they're pretty narrow they're pretty
small and they indicate they give us
confidence that we have pretty accurate
estimates of the true trajectory this
kind of confidence intervals that we
have discussed in the context of this
example are called Bayesian confidence
intervals and they're very useful when
you report your results to not just give
point estimates but to also provide
confidence intervals coming back to the
bigger picture what happened in this
particular example is quite indicative
of many real-world applications one
starts with a linear model in which we
have a linear relation between the
variables that are unknown and the
observations but we're also the
observations are corrupted by noise one
makes certain normality and independence
assumptions and as long as the modeling
has been done carefully and the
assumptions are justified then by
carrying out this procedure one usually
obtains estimates that very helpful and
very informative